>> Steven Levingston: Good
afternoon and welcome.
I'm Steve Levingston
non-fiction book editor
of the Washington Post
which is a charter sponsor
of the National Book Festival.
First a couple of
housekeeping things.
We'd like to extend
a word of thanks
to the festival's
co-chairman David Rubenstein
and the other generous sponsors
who've made this event possible.
[ Applause ]
>> Steven Levingston:
And if you'd
like to contribute your
financial support there's some
information about
that in the program.
Before we begin I've
been asked to remind you
that these events are being
recorded by the Library
of Congress, which may broadcast
them at some future date.
After our author's
presentation there will be time
for questions, but if you
don't want to become perm --
the library's permanent
collection, it may be best
to let someone else
ask the questions.
Many people have the
look of brilliance.
There are many people
who sound brilliant
but few people have
both of those qualities
and a third most important one.
They prove their brilliance.
Steve Coll is that rare person.
His works speak for itself.
He's a two time winner of the
Pulitzer Prize once a reporter
for the Washington Post
for his overage of the SEC
and another time for
his book Ghost Wars,
his account of the CIA's
role in Afghanistan.
Now he's dean of
Columbia Journalism School
and a staff writer
at the New Yorker.
I was honored to work under
him when he was managing editor
of the Washington Post.
Steve has written eight books.
These include the breakup
of AT&T, an exploration
of Exxon Mobile's power and a
history of the Bin Laden family.
His latest book Directorate S
is a follow-up to Ghost Wars.
It takes us into the
aftermath of the US invasion
of Afghanistan in 2001
and the U.S. experience
over the next 17 years, which
can be described as one --
as one reviewed put
it best as "A period
of American ignorance,
atrocity and error."
Reviewers have called the book
impressive and definitive.
They have noted the 550
interviews Steve conducted.
Their praised as
literary prowess.
But the story Steve tells
is a dispiriting one.
As the New York Times wrote
"The topic is important.
The treatment compelling.
The conclusions persuasive."
But that reviewer
Andrew Bacavich noted
that America's policy
makers are not listening
and are not taking
Steve's reporting to heart.
"Just don't expect anything
to change" Bacavich
said, concluded sadly.
Steve is a force for
illumination and understanding
of America's past and present.
So please welcome me -- please
join me in welcoming Steve Call.
[ Applause ]
>> Steve Coll: Thank
you so much Steve.
Thank you all for coming out.
I really enjoyed working with
Steve and fantastic colleagues
at the Washington Post.
I miss them a lot so I'm always
glad to get back to Washington.
And I'm also glad to get back to
a city that has so many people
in public service and engaged
in international policy,
which are kind of my subjects.
I wonder just a quick show
of hands how many people
in this room have been
to Afghanistan since 2001
in service in one
way or another?
Yeah a significant number.
So.
[ Applause ]
>> Steve Coll: I have about 30
minutes to introduce the book
to you so I'm going to
have to be efficient.
As you might notice
it's not a thin book.
And so the way I try to
give you a flavor of it is
by giving you a sense of what
it's about, where it came
and what story it tells.
But mostly what are,
what are several
of the most important themes
in this history that I can try
to draw out and give you
a little bit of flavor for
and then I look forward -- I'll
read a little bit at one stage
as well just to give
you a flavor of some
of the reporting on the ground.
Then I look forward
to your questions.
So in February 1989 the
final armored column
of the limited contingent of
Soviet forces in Afghanistan
as the Soviet occupation
army was called crossed
over the Friendship bridge
of the Amu Darya River,
officially ending
the Soviet occupation
of Afghanistan during
the 1980's.
General Gromov was the final
Soviet commander and he got
down from the last
armored personnel carrier
and turned his back on
Afghanistan and walked out
and was greeted by his son who
gave him a bouquet of flowers.
That's how the Soviet war ended.
In December 2014 the Obama
administration thought it was
ending the war in Afghanistan
although it intended to stay
and hand off support
in an advisory role
under operation resolution
support.
But none the less the United
States at that time thought
that it's combat operations
direct combat operations
in Afghanistan were ending
so they held a ceremony
in a gymnasium in the bunkered
and fortified headquarters
of the International
Security Assistance Force
in Afghanistan in Kabul.
And they handed out, they
had some military bands.
They were -- but they were
very well inside an area
that they sometimes
had experienced
of being rocketed in.
So they handed out kind of
a program for the ceremony
that included instructions about
how to get down on the floor
and cover your head in
the event of rocketing.
So that was how the
U.S. war ended once.
And then a year later
it started again.
And today as you know
we're still actually
in direct combat
operations in Afghanistan.
We're fighting two
wars there one directly
against the Islamic state
al-Qaeda affiliated groups.
And then another that
advisor and assist war that,
that we thought we were
moving into in 2014.
So it's been 17 years.
A lot of frustration.
A lot of sacrifice.
Hundreds and thousands
of Americans volunteered
over the course of those
years to serve in Afghanistan.
More than 2,000 American
soldiers died
as did hundreds of contractors.
More than 20,000 soldiers
suffered injuries.
The casualties among Afghans and
Pakistani's were even greater.
The war that, that followed the
end of the American invasion
in 2001 caused about 140,000
deaths directly by the end
of 2014 according to
estimates by researchers
at Brown University and 10
of thousands more since then.
And of course Afghans
and Pakistani's have
suffered the most losses,
even greater losses.
So why over so many years
and despite some many efforts
and strategies has the
United States failed
to achieve its goals
in Afghanistan?
Has it failed to bank
with the Taliban,
failed to stabilize the country,
failed to create a
self-sustaining independent
constitutional republic
or democracy of some sort.
It's a long story.
It's a complicated story,
but as I say I want to draw
out a few themes and
tell a few stories
around what I think are some
of the recurring
problems in the war.
So the first is the
problem of war aims.
Why are we there?
Which was a question that was
of course never really formally
addressed before we invaded
Afghanistan because
the war was a hurried
and a provisional response to
September 11th attacks designed
to disrupt al-Qaeda which was
in Afghanistan and had carried
out the attacks substantially
from there.
To disrupt their leadership
before they could launch what
was presumed to be
following attacks.
And so the war never really
reckoned with what Afghanistan
after the invasion would be
because it was really
being conceived within two
or three weeks of the shock
of the September 11th attacks.
So in the subsequent period
after the Taliban fell
at the end of 2001 and al-Qaeda
largely escaped Afghanistan
and migrated into Pakistan, the
war since then has been plagued
by recurring arguments and
confusion over war aims.
I want to talk about that.
Second thing that has really
been repetitive although it was
confined to the period
when Hamid Karzai was
in office was the failure to
consolidate a relationship
with Karzai that would
serve American interests
in the transition to
a post Karzai world.
We, we really lost our
relationship with Karzai and,
and our investments
in democratic Afghan
politics also faltered,
not only because of our
conductor or decision making.
Afghans had a lot to do with
that too, but I think the,
the story of the failure
of the relationship
with Harmon Karzai is
particularly interesting
because it goes to the
big problem of Pakistan.
The biggest puzzle I think
for a lot of people who served
in the war and certainly
for a lot
of Afghans throughout the war
after 2001 and particularly
when the Taliban started to
revive around 2004 or 2005
in seriousness, was
why the United States
and NATO were willing
to accept the sanctuary
and the support the
Taliban enjoyed,
still enjoy across the
border in Pakistan even
when Pakistan was receiving
hundreds of millions of dollars
in U.S. aid and even
after it became obvious
that the Taliban were
prevailing or certainly working
up a pretty bloody
stalemate in Afghanistan
because of the sanctuary
and the training and the aid
that they enjoyed
covertly from Pakistan
and from Pakistan's principle
intelligence service,
Interviews Intelligence or ISI.
The title of the book
Directorate S refers
to the covert action arm.
It's what the American's
sometimes called the,
the covert action arm of ISI,
the Pakistanian Intelligence
Service that works with groups
like the Taliban related
groups in Cashmere to carry
out what Pakistan's army sees
as its foreign policy
interests in the region.
Of course the American's
knew all about ISI
because we had collaborated
with them during the 1980's
during the Soviet Union along
with Saudi intelligence, we
pumped billions of dollars
into the Alphagan rebel
force based in Pakistan.
That also prevailed
of the Soviet Union
because it enjoyed this physical
sanctuary and covert aid
that we participated in.
So why, why did we fail
to recognize ISI's revival
and why did it turn out
to be so flummoxing?
Something we can talk about.
Alright so that's the real
principle narrative of the book.
It opens -- Ghost Wars closes
on the eve of the 9 11 attacks.
It's about the, the history
between the Soviet
invasion and 9 11.
And this is intended
as a second volume
of Ghost Wars although its kind
o f a funny thing as a writer
to write a second volume of
a book that wasn't intended
to be the first of two, but
that's kind of what this is.
And it ends where Ghost Wars
stops quite deliberately
and comes forward to
something like the present day
and has many of the same
reporting and narrative,
story-telling strategies
as the first volume.
Alright so I promised to go over
this, this subject of war aims.
One of the things-- you know
I was kind of a beat reporter
on the war after 9 11 because
I had accidental expertise
about Afghanistan.
I had been assigned out
there by the Washington Post
as a foreign correspondent.
I had covered the war
on the ground long before 9 11
before anyone was really very
interested in it.
But it was a -- I, I became kind
of a professional obsession
and a great interest.
I loved the landscape and the
people that I met in Afghanistan
and Pakistan and I found
the war and the structure
of covert action that shaped
so much misery and radicalism
in the region to be
an important subject
and one that fascinated me.
But after 9 11 because of that
background I kept going back
to the region Pakistan
and Afghanistan doing
a lot of reporting.
And I, and I also was a creature
of Washington covering the
National Security bureaucracy
and interagency debates
about U.S. Policy
in Afghanistan and in the war.
And so when I went
back to do the research
to really excavate the history
of decision making in Washington
about policy in the Afghan war
and policy toward Pakistan,
I was surprised and a
little bit disheartened
to encounter what I didn't
fully appreciate as a kind
of beat reporter which is the
repetitive nature of the debates
about why are we in Afghanistan
and who is our enemy?
The Busch administration
through several phases,
right up until the
last days and months
of the Bush administration
convened
in a classified conference room
in the Eisenhower
Executive Office Building
which is next door
to the White House.
If you're walking by the
White House it's over there
to the right, that very
ornate looking building,
on the fourth floor.
And they would typically
spend a whole day wrestling
over what direction to
take in Afghanistan.
They'd have the intelligence
analyst come in, in the morning
and try to brief the facts.
This is what the map looks like.
These are, these are the,
the principle ethnic groups.
Here are the principle factions.
And then they would leave and
the policy makers would debate.
And they would get to
these basic questions.
Are the Taliban our enemy?
There were no Afghans'
on the planes on 9 11.
So far known the Afghan
Taliban have never carried
out a terrorist attack
as an organization
against the United States
in the U.S. or in Europe.
They were attacked initially
because they were correctly seen
as providing sanctuary
to al-Qaeda.
Their alliance with al-Qaeda
was always uneasy and debatable.
And so in these policy decisions
starting in 2006 repeating
in 2008 and in 209 and in 2012
and in 2014, the best minds
in the U.S. government.
The best informed south Asia
policy makers would return
to this conference room,
write up white papers try
to develop recommendations
to the president.
And one of the questions they
kept returning too is what are
our vital interests
in Afghanistan
that justify the kinds of
sacrifices that we ask young men
and women in uniform
to make over there?
And an example would be in
2009 during the first year
of the Obama administration
a new group came in went back
to the same conference room,
picked up the white papers
that the Bush administration
had left behind went back
to this question.
And they were cleared eyed about
what the question should be.
As taxpayers you would want them
to be asking what vital
interests really justify this
kind of military sacrifice?
And they worked on that
for weeks and months.
And in the end they
identified two.
One was al-Qaeda which
was still carrying
out international attacks
from the, from the region
against the United States,
attempting attacks inside
the United States also
in Europe and elsewhere.
And the second was the security
of Pakistani's nuclear weapons
because Pakistan has
about 100 nuclear weapons.
It has a lot of radical
groups on its soil.
And the nightmare scenario would
be if somehow Pakistan became
so destabilized that
these weapons fell
into the wrong hands.
But consider this contradiction,
the first of half a dozen
that we can review over
the next 20 minutes.
Neither al-Qaeda nor
Pakistani's nuclear weapons were
in Afghanistan in 2009,
where the president was
about to send 100,000 troops.
So if the vital interests are
in Pakistan why are we fighting
a war next door in Afghanistan?
The, the president's
advisors were smart enough
to understand this
contradiction,
so they wrestled with it.
And they said "Well it's
sort of an indirect reason
because if Afghanistan
falls apart,
then al-Qaeda will come
back into Afghanistan
and that may also
destabilize Pakistan.
So we've got to shore up
this neighbor in order
to pursue the vital
interests that are next door."
I don't know.
I mean as a parent sending
a child into harm's way,
that feels a little bit indirect
to me as a, as a, as a war aim.
Well the other war aim then
that might justify this sort
of sacrifice is you are
going to fight the Taliban.
You're going to prevent
the Taliban
from consolidating the momentum
which by 2009 it had quite a lot
of on the ground in Afghanistan.
But the policy makers
including --
particularly during the early
Obama years were really divided
about whether the Taliban
should be understood as an enemy
of the United States partly
for the reasons I described.
They're indigenous
to Afghanistan.
It was pointed out
in these debates.
They are part of the
fabric of southern
and eastern Afghanistan.
They have, they have
not declared war
against the Unites States.
They're abhorrent.
Their ideas are abhorrent.
We certainly don't want
them to take power.
But are they an enemy?
The truth was that President
Obama did not believe the United
States should attempt to fight a
forever war against the Taliban
and that there was
neither the political clock
in the Unites States nor the
resources nor the prospect
of military victory to
justify such an endeavor.
But his generals had
sold him on the idea
of a counter insurgency
war that could succeed
in Afghanistan the way it was
perceived to have succeeded
in Bagdad after the
surge at there in 2006.
And so the president
was reluctant
to at least initially --
that's a funnier
conversation than Afghanistan.
Let's make some noise in here.
Sorry. People are.
[ Applause, Cheering ]
>> Steve Coll: It's hard to
get a laugh out of fighting
and dying, but we'll
keep trying.
Anyway there's a scene where
the president basically makes it
known through his White House
aid's that he doesn't want
to fight this forever
war against the Taliban,
so his aids go into this
secure conference room
or the situation room
one day and they say
"Have we ever really
said that it was our aim
to defeat the Taliban?"
And the Pentagon
representatives are appalled.
And the next day they come
back with a big PowerPoint deck
that shows all the
different statements
that American presidents
and senators have made
about our intention to
vanquish the Taliban
from the face of the earth.
They say, "You may not
want to fight this war,
but you've said you've
signed up for it."
And, and so yes we have declared
our interest in defeating it.
But when the troop surge
announcements were made,
if you parsed that language,
he's very careful not to declare
that we intend to defeat the
Taliban on the battlefield.
The, the war aim was to reduce
or reverse the Taliban's
momentum to create space
for Afghan forces to take the
lead and, and essentially kind
of Vietnmization
of the Afghan war.
And that was achieved.
It still has been
achieved today.
The war is a stalemate now,
just as it was in 2007.
One of the episodes the book
described repeatedly is this --
these very popular
classified maps
that the CIA would produce
called the District Assessments
which were derived from a
similar mapping exercise carried
out during the Vietnam War.
They would take all
of approximately --
Afghanistan spans
approximately 400 districts,
administrative districts
and color code them based
on the latest intelligence and
open information as to whether
or not they're controlled
by the Taliban or controlled
by the Afghan government,
contested or locally controlled
by some other war lord.
And essentially they would
come in and unfurl these maps.
Everyone would poor over them
looking for subtle changes.
The reality is they haven't
changed color in 10 years.
They're made every six months
and things move around.
And green appears here
and red appears there.
The wars stalemated
and it's stalemated
because the Taliban have no air
force and they have no answer
for the U.S. Air Force, so they
can't mask very successfully.
But also neither
the NATO led troops
which after peak numbered
150,000 in Afghanistan in 2010.
Nor the Afghan forces after we
reduced our presence has had an
answer for the sanctuary in
Pakistan for the role of ISI
and supporting the
Taliban in the war
or for the Taliban's coercive
control of quite a lot
of rural districts particularly
in the south and east.
Loosing Hamid Karzai.
Again as a beat reporter
I, I covered Hamid Karzai
for a long time over the years.
I've interviewed him
a couple of times
and watched him in
press conferences.
He's a fascinating figure
and certainly was as,
as he became the
unexpected president
of Afghanistan after 2001.
And I thought I understood
him reasonably well.
I was aware certainly by the
time I was working on this book
that he had gained a reputation
as being this very
unstable individual
who was constantly going off and
attacking the United States and,
and kind of involved
in conspiracy theories
and that sort of thing.
Again I was surprised when
I kind of excavated as many
of the private conversations
that he had with his own cabinet
or with the American's
that he was very consistent
over the years about one thing.
Every time an American would
come to visit him he would say,
"You're not doing enough to
put pressure on Pakistan.
These sanctuaries
are unacceptable.
And ISI's interference
in the war is going
to make the war unwinnable.
Why are you not doing this?
Why are you not -- why
are you treating them
as if this isn't going on?"
And the American's
at first would say,
"Well yeah I don't think you
understand President Musharraf
who is seen as a reliable
ally of the United States.
He's a friend.
He's trying to do his best."
Later the American's agreed
that ISI was a problem
but they felt they couldn't put
too much pressure on Pakistan
because after all Pakistan
itself was convulsed
by internal violence caused
in part by the migration
of al-Qaeda into Pakistan.
They had the worst domestic
terrorism they ever experienced
in 2009, 2010.
And if a vital interest
of the United States was
preventing Pakistan's nuclear
weapons from getting
into the wrong hands,
you couldn't very well and go in
and exacerbate the
almost civil war
that Pakistan was
experiencing at that point.
Nonetheless, we kept
confusing Karzai by kind
of fluffing off his question.
In the summer of 2008
then candidate Obama flew
into Afghanistan on a
campaign visit and he went
to meet Karzai and his cabinet.
And this cabinet
really they all didn't
like each other very much.
They rarely cooperated on much,
but they all got together
before the meeting and said,
"Let's agree to emphasize,
to possible President Obama
that it's all about ISI.
It's all about Pakistan."
So when each of them
went around the table
and said something they all
said, "You really have to focus
on this problem because
the sanctuary is going
to make the war unwinnable."
And when the United States
didn't do anything about it,
worse, when the United States
made it clear to Karzai
that it thought that maybe
Pakistan was actually more
important to the United
States than Afghanistan,
he understandably
became deeply confused.
There's a scene in the book
where Vice-President
Joe Biden goes out early
on in the Obama Administration
to meet with Karzai.
The Obama Administration
came in and a lot
of the administrations come
no matter which party it is
and they think whatever the
last guys did was exactly wrong
so we're going to
do the opposite.
And one of the syndromes
and this case was
that the Obama folks thought
that the Busch administration
particularly President Bush
personally had coddled Karzai,
had spent too much
time holding his hand.
Had, had accommodated
too much corruption,
too much drug dealing and it
was time to get tough on him.
So Biden was sent out to deliver
this message, you know the,
the era of the friendly
video conference is over.
You, you got to clean up your
act and you can't expect us
to accommodate you the way
the last administration did.
So he's goes into this
private meeting with Karzai.
Karzai starts the
meeting by saying,
"You know Mr. Vice-President,
you really need
to do more about Pakistan.
You really need to
do more about ISI."
And Biden replies,
"Mr. President,
Pakistan is 50 times
more important
to the United States
than Afghanistan."
So maybe not the most diplomatic
way to put pressure on Karzai.
But you know in a lot of
south Asia and certainly a lot
of similar parts of the
world, it's common to sink
into conspiracy thinking.
And the way it wet for Karzai
was when he looked at the fact
that the United States wasn't
putting any pressure on Pakistan
and that Pakistan
was by the admission
of many American Generals
and intelligence officers,
that's its role in
the war was critical.
He began to think well the
United States must want Pakistan
to be reviving the Taliban.
He must want Pakistan to be
destabilizing Afghanistan.
He must want the American -- the
American's must want this war
to grind on so that they can
justify having a long-term
military presence
in the country.
This is the kind of
confusion that you can create.
Now diplomat after diplomat,
general after general would go
to Karzai and say,
"No Mr. President,
there's no such conspiracy.
We're just doing our best to
try to keep this war going
in the right direction."
But Karzai was absolutely
convinced that the American's
after a certain point were
deliberately allowing ISI
to create this war so
that they could justify a
long-term presence.
At one point a guy named Jim
Dobbin's in 2013 he goes out
and meets with Karzai to try
to talk him out of this idea.
He says, "Mr. President, by now
you've got the Snowden material,
the Wiki Leaks, millions
of documents.
Read them.
Can you see any trace of
this plan, this conspiracy
that you're attributing to us?"
And Karzai looks
at him and says,
"Well maybe you don't
know the plan.
Maybe you're not briefed."
"You know there is a deep
state in America", he said.
Okay. A lot of the book tries
to describe how these
decisions cascaded,
built one on another how these
misunderstandings developed
at the highest levels among
decision makers in Washington
and Islamabad, and Kabul.
But I also felt that I should
try to write about the war
as it was experienced on
the ground, and particularly
after the United States launched
this counter-insurgency campaign
in southern Afghanistan
in 2010, 2009, 2010, 2011.
It was a war very distant war.
Didn't get quite all of the
attention the reality of it.
I don't think quite
soaked through.
It was a volunteer army fighting
in very difficult terrain.
But it was a product of a kind
of faith encounter
insurgency expeditionary
counter insurgency.
As I mentioned followed out of
the perceived success in Bagdad.
And if you were in town, in
national security circles
in Washington, circa 2009
2010 it was like a bubble.
It was like a Bit coin or
some other kind of sense,
self reinforcing sense that
his idea is going to solve it.
We're going to go
out there we're going
to run this counter insurgency
campaign, connecting people
to their government,
walking through villages,
fighting it out one
path at a time.
And it turned out I
places like Kandahar
to be a very violent war.
And so I looked for a
way to tell the story
through one unit's experience
in the heart of the campaign.
And I chose the part of the
campaign that was fought in the
so called green zone to
the, to the west of Kandahar
which is the Taliban's
birth place significant city
in the south of Afghanistan.
It's called the green zone
because though it's desert,
there's the Arghandab
river flows through it
and irrigation is
made possible much
of the year through this river.
And the vegetation around
in this green zone is
incredibly thick.
That's great orchards
with drying houses
and berms almost worse
than Normandy in terms
of terrain to try to fight in.
And foliage that's almost jungle
like in the canopy it creates.
10 foot marijuana plants
being a feature of this.
Big marijuana farming industry.
One of the jobs the American's
had was to go out and cut
down these 10 foot plants
then set them on fire
which was not always
objected to as duty.
But it was -- the Taliban had
been imbedding in this zone for,
for years and years
and they build an
incredible infrastructure.
And the, and the purpose of the
counter insurgency campaign was
to go in and knock them
out once and for all.
So I'll just read you
a little passage from,
from that campaign.
The flavor of it.
"So the initial phase of
Colonel Art Kandarian's campaign
in the green zone wasn't
that much different of that
of the U.S. Army in the American
West during the 19th century.
Build forts in Indian
country and poke around.
Forward American units
detains suspected insurgents
and used retinal scanners to log
them into classified data bases,
but interrogations and human
intelligence collection
in Kandahar that summer rarely
produced insights besides the
known fact that many
Taliban fighters were from
or trained in Pakistan."
So the platoons that I write
about were former artillery
units that had been converted
to infantry because
during this period
of the war the United States
military was so stressed
by the cascading consequences
of fighting hard in Iraq
and Afghanistan at
the same time,
that they were piecing
together task forces
out of different units.
And they were asking
artillery men
to fight close infantry patrol
wars with a lot of IED's
and implanted explosives.
And, and this is you know a lot
of these artillery men had been
trained to fight with big guns
on bases at a remote distance.
They were engineers and
they weren't used to this.
They -- so they would build
these outposts in the middle
of the green zone, barely
being able to see five feet
over the wall and then they
would go out and patrol on foot
by contact, trying to just
draw the Taliban into contact.
"Platoons depended on their
most experienced sergeants
to survive.
Sergeant Josh Strickland had
served two tours in Iraq and one
in Afghanistan before joining
third platoon a battery
of the 1-320th the
artillery misfits.
During the first couple of weeks
of -- at combat outpost Noland,
Strickland's patrol
could not walk 100 years
without hitting an
IED or getting lit
up by Taliban from
several sides.
Listening to the enemy radio
talk they learned the enemy knew
they were artillery
not infantry.
In general, Strickland thought
the lowest ranking first time
soldiers adjusted
to the stress better
than the more experienced
artillery men
because the rookies
had no expectations
from prior deployments.
Because of Strickland's
experience and uncanny ability
to avoid IED's soldiers
continually asked him
to walk point on their patrols.
He chose to walk 10 to 15
feet ahead of everyone else
so that he could carefully
identify the best route and so
that if he did make a mistake
it would cost one life instead
of several.
He was ultimately
wounded and medivaced
to Kandahar airfield four times.
Each time as he recovered
in the hospital a doctor would
ask Strickland if he wanted
to go back or go home.
"What am I going to say?"
he thought.
He went back.
Day after day they
shouldered their loads,
stepped on presence patrols
and hoped for the best.
They walked past villagers
near their outposts
who were neither
helpful nor hostile.
One elder near Strickland's
base kept a pigeon
that he would let fly every
time a platoon departed,
apparently to let the Taliban
know they were on the march.
By July IED's and the escalating
casualties had rattled the most
experienced infantry men.
Every soldier carried
70 to 90 pounds
of gear, water and ammunition.
They patrolled at
night to avoid the sun.
They drank water continually
to stave off dehydration.
The IED's were so thick
around the bulldog encampment
that they had to clear 100 years
at a time from the walls out.
A lot of soldiers
struggled with the stress.
The first platoon of the
1-320th started out with 19 men.
After three patrols, they had 6.
80%, 80% Bravo company's
personnel had
to be replaced during
Strickland's tour
because of combat
vets severed limbs,
concussions or other injuries."
Now you think of those
percentages, I mean that sound
like Battle of the Bulge.
Wasn't, it -- wasn't present
in American life
that part of the war.
And one of the reasons
that I want to finish
on the last theme I
want to touch on is
because we really didn't
have a national debate
about the war during the time
that these sacrifices
were being sought.
And we also failed to
reckon with the kind
of political strategy that was
necessary given the history
of wars of this kind to really
fashion any kind of exit
from the war that
would be sustainable.
One of the contradictions that
keeps recurring in history is
that every general who
goes out to command.
They command usually for a
year at a time, maybe two years
at a time If there, if
they stay for a long while.
Every general who goes out for
the American effort will say,
"There is no military victory
possible against the Taliban.
The only way this
war will end will be
through political negotiations
and some kind of settlement."
And yet again and again
military action is, is,
is resourced ahead of
political strategy.
And there is very little
effort of a serious kind made
to bring the regional
powers, the great powers,
the international system
into negotiation to
stabilize the war.
The book recounts this very
interesting secret negotiation
the Obama administration
carried out with the Taliban
between 2010 and 2013.
It failed for a bunch
of reasons.
The Trump administration is
trying something similar now.
But it was always treated
as kind of a Hail Mary pass
and never given the serious
international attention
that for example
accompanied the efforts
to cap Iran's nuclear program
with the P5 powers in Europe
and everyone else involved.
It's kind of a tragedy that we
keep repeating the same strategy
again and again.
And expecting a different
result, while asking
for such large sacrifices
from our own soldiers
and those of our allies.
Thank you for listening.
I'll take a few questions.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you for your remarks.
Really appreciated that.
In your discussion you
talked about American aims,
what about the Pakistani aims
and specifically the
Pakistan's interest in India,
and how that plays
out in Afghanistan?
>> Steve Coll: Great question.
So and it's a big
part of the book.
Short version Pakistan's foreign
policy and military policy
of course is very heavily
influenced by its army,
so the outlook of civilian
politicians is much less
relevant when you talk about
something like Afghanistan.
And, and as you say Pakistan's
army principle concern is India
in which it believes seeks
Pakistan's demilitarization
or dismemberment.
And the Pakistan army discovered
with our help during the 1980's
that his asymmetric strategy
of supporting Islamist militia
groups against India in,
in the region was a successful
way for a smaller country
with a smaller population
and a less powerful economy
to hold its own to deter India.
And so that's been their
historical strategy
and Afghanistan has been part
of it is why Pakistan was one
of only three countries
in the world
that recognized the
Taliban government
when it ruled Afghanistan
in the 1990's.
They see India as kind
of using Afghanistan
to sort of encircle Pakistan.
And then they have a direct
confrontation to their east.
The -- a [inaudible] question
is why did Pakistan go back
into partnership with the
Taliban after 2005 2006?
Because for all of Pervez
Musharraf's limitations
as Pakistan's military
leader and president,
there was a period in 2002 2003
where he was arresting a lot
of al-Qaeda figures
cooperating a lot
with the United States
on counter terrorism.
Looking not to particularly
get involved with the Taliban.
I think probably just
hoping they would fade away.
But several years later
it became clear first
to front line American officers
and intelligence collectors
and then eventually
to the whole cabinet,
that ISI was back in action.
That they were going back
to the same old strategies
they'd used before.
And then so why, why did
the high command make
that decision 2004 2005 2006?
A kind of a mystery that I
worked on in my research.
I'm not saying -- I don't
think I solved it entirely,
but I think there were a
couple of important factors.
One was that the Pakistani's
sense of our involvement
in Afghanistan and with them
over the years is
we're not reliable.
We come, we go.
We come in when we
need something.
As soon as we have
it then we go.
And in 2004 and 2005 we
were all fighting in Iraq.
And the Bush administration's
view was
that Iraq was the main effort
and that Afghanistan was
at peace and they turned
over security in the country
to NATO allies and declined
to resource significant American
commitment to the country.
And so when the Pakistani
general saw the Dutch coming
in to provide security
in southern Afghanistan,
and they saw the American's
concentrating in Iraq,
they basically said
to themselves
"So we've seen this
movie before.
They're, they're going home.
They're leaving us with this
neighborhood and India's going
to take advantage of this if
we don't defend our interests."
That was one reason.
I think the second
was around this time,
United States did this
big strategic nuclear deal
with India.
India's a natural
21st Century ally
of the United States
in a lot of ways.
And they wanted India
to, to feel rewarded
in strategic partnership.
But they essentially said
to the Indian government,
"We forgive you for having
a nuclear weapons program.
And, and you're now legitimate
as a partner of ours."
And we said to the
Pakistani's at the same time,
"You're not getting this deal.
You're not reliable enough.
You give away your nuclear
weapons to through [inaudible]."
Pakistani's said, "Okay
you've made yourself clear.
India's your strategic,
your strategic ally
for the 21st Century.
We're your rent a cop.
You know we're going to get
after our own interests."
And I think that's a lot
of why they went back to,
to pursuing the Taliban's
revival.
Yes?
>> Thanks so much for
your presentation.
My question is do you think
that the debate on this war
and on many recent
wars would be enhanced
if we reintroduced
the, the draft?
>> Steve Coll: It's really
interesting question.
I mean you know the,
the strength
of the American military as an
institution, as a journalist
if you encounter it, you can
see many of its great strengths.
And they're rooted in the, in
the revival of a volunteer army
after the debacle of the Vietnam
War and the effects it had
on the, on the military
as an institution.
But I'm so struck at how
segregated the experience
of sacrifice has been in both
wars because of the geography
of volunteerism in the country.
And I do think that a lot
of the populism and disgust
that the country has expressed
about its decision making
elites particularly in some
of the states and
communities that volunteered
to follow leaders into
these wars, is located in a,
in a kind of uneven
understanding of the failures
of these wars of the,
of the promises betrayed
and the price paid even where
the sacrifices seen as noble.
The extraordinary price that's
paid by people coming home with,
with missing limbs
and, and broken spirits
from repeated concussions
and so forth.
So I, I'm personally
I kind of --
it's not fashionable in
the zip code where I live,
but I think national public
service is a, is a good policy
and it doesn't have to all be
conscripted military service
to be successful but these kinds
of sacrifices should
not be isolated
from our shared experiences.
And they are.
They were in this case.
Yes?
[ Applause ]
>> You're description of ISI in
Pakistan makes it sound sort of,
not to be facetious, but like
the deep state of Pakistan.
So two questions.
What, what is Imran Khan's
relationship going to be to ISI?
And secondly coming back to Sy
Hersh's alternative scenario
for the, the capture
and killing of,
of al-Qaeda's you
know Bin Laden,
do you put any credence in that?
>> Steve Coll: So Imran Khan
is a really fascinating figure.
I wrote a profile about him in
the New Yorker in 2012 I think
when he was first
bursting onto the scene.
He was a very entertaining
person to hang
around with and write about.
So if you are interested in him
I -- you can find that online.
At the time I went back and read
it when he became Prime Minister
and I was surprised at that time
he really spoke pretty boldly
about the army which is not
a thing to do in Pakistan
if you want a political future.
He was critical of the army
very openly at that time.
But I think he's seen now
as having become
partner of the army.
And the army has -- made
a very clear decision
and understandable one
that it doesn't want
to rule Pakistan directly.
The reputational costs,
the institutional costs,
the costs in the
international system are high.
Better to rule indirectly
through civilian politicians
who can deal with the domestic
problems of the economy
of negotiating with the
IMF, of all of the problems
that Pakistan perennially
endures.
And so Imran Khan I think
has been willing to cooperate
or to share space with the army.
You know there're debates
about how much of lackey
of the army he is, but I think
the record is he's stopped
criticizing them and he's
accepted their clear kind
of frame work of support
for him to take power.
Will he be able to
accomplish anything?
I'm, I'm doubtful.
And I, I think he might be able
to do a few things domestically,
particularly with his
anti-corruption drives.
But in foreign policy clearly
that belongs to the army
and I don't -- if he tries
to move in that direction --
every civilian politician
who has tried
to challenge the army's ideas
about regional policy and,
and foreign policy has lost
office in a, in a coup or kind
of indirect electoral coup.
So he knows that history.
That goes back 30, 40 years.
>> Hersh's Story.
>> Steve Coll: Oh Hersh's story.
I, I mean Sy is an American
legend and a colleague
and someone I respect
a great deal.
And so all I can say is I
researched that same subject
and I didn't see
evidence for the, the,
the account that he obtained
from the unknown sources
because they're, they're
just background sources.
I, I, I didn't find
those sources.
You know Sy he does
have a record sometimes
of reporting things that
seem couldn't possibly be
and it turns out it's true.
So I you know in
Pakistan I'm willing
to believe anything
about Pakistan.
But I, I, I really worked
that thing pretty hard and I,
I don't see evidence for
those, for those claims.
Do I have time for one more?
Wrap it up I'm told.
So I've got a card that
says literally wrap it up.
So we'll -- you're going
to have the last word.
>> Thank you so much.
I will not apologize if I
offend anybody because I --
as you can hear I'm,
I'm not from here.
I'm originally from Poland.
Living in Canada now.
So I hope my question
won't sound like hostile.
But I, I think like --
especially Like I remember
watching the movie Charlie
[inaudible] many, many years
ago and there was this scene
when Charlie goes to like
CIA or government and he ask
about like Afghanistan or
like central Asia department.
And there's like three kids
from fresh out of college.
And, and I think what really
like considering the American
involvement or not now
like I think some
places especially people
from other countries with
all due respect for like,
like soldiers fighting, American
soldiers and Canadian soldiers
in other countries,
soldiers fighting
and sacrificing their life.
Is there really like some
kind of a government body
that like has like a
really good knowledge
and understanding of the area?
>> Steve Coll: Yeah.
So it's, it's, a great question.
I think expertise
about Afghanistan
and Pakistan was scant on 9 11.
And it was a problem.
There really wasn't
anyone in the cabinet
who had experience
of the region first.
I'm not sure there was anyone in
the cabinet or the senior ranks
of the administration
who've actually been
in Afghanistan on as of 9 11.
Compow [phonetic],
Richard Armistead
of the state department knew
the region reasonably well,
but primarily collaborating
with the Pakistan army
during the first Gulf War.
And so their perspective was
very much located around the,
the stabilizing force
of the Pakistan army.
And that influenced some
of the early debates.
There were CIA people who knew
quite a lot about the resistance
to the Taliban because they'd
been working with them.
And they did get to the table
and offered some initial advice.
But as a broad matter I think
the failure to see ISI go back
into action until it was pretty
much too late in 2007, 2008,
was partly a function of the
lack of high level understanding
about the complexities
of the war
and the complexities
of the region.
A lot of it, more of it was
about the distraction of Iraq.
But I think that was a factor.
And then for those of us
who would, who would --
been working on this and, and
were really engaged with it,
it was frustrating
sometimes to think
that our government really
didn't get it at some level.
By 2008 I -- by 2007, 2008
I wouldn't say that anymore.
I mean I knew enough
of the people
who were making decisions.
The army had been out in the
field, people multiple tours.
You had a lot of Dari speakers
and Pashto speakers going
into the military now.
You had a cabinet that had
finally really spent a lot
of time with this problem.
I think by 2000, 2007, 2008 the
cabinet level decision makers
yeah they did understand
what the problem was.
And I used to go around
to, to friends in 2009,
2010 I was working
down here at the time.
I'd say "You know
finally everybody
in the system understands
what's going on.
The problem is that doesn't
make it possible to solve it."
Nobody you know that,
that clarity has not produced
insights about how to,
how to untie this knot.
And, and you still see
that happening today.
Yeah but there the expertise
accumulated at a great cost
and it wasn't the expertise
of a, of a solution.
Thank you all.